in one of the largest ever murder cases
against a healthcare professional a
former doctor in a home in Ohio is
accused in the overdose killings of more
than two dozen patients William Hewson
pleaded not guilty yesterday to 25
counts of murder CTM investigative
correspondent and a Warner is following
the case Anna how far back to these
allegations go well Tony the criminal
investigation has been going on for
about six months now Hewson was fired by
his Columbus area hospital in December
prosecutors say he gave excessive
amounts of painkillers to the patients
over the course of three years hastening
the deaths of some possibly causing the
deaths of others I'm just kind of numb
to him right now and what happened and
what he did to my mom prosecutors say
Amy faff smother Beverly shirt singer
could have improved with proper medical
treatment but they say she died after
her dr. William Hewson prescribed a
fatal dose of the powerful painkiller
fentanyl the fact he gave it to one
patient then gave it to another and
yousell is charged in the overdose
deaths of 25 patients between 2015 and
2018 according to investigators he
ordered doses that were between 10 and
40 times greater than deemed medically
appropriate he allegedly told many
family members the same story he told
Christine allison whose husband Troy was
in a truck accident
she says Huston told her oh no he's
dying
no I'm 99.9% sure he is brain dead in
February we spoke with Allison and other
family members who lost loved ones under
Hughes care Allison says her husband was
dead three hours after getting to the
hospital after it was over we go down
the parking garage I looked at my
daughter and I said what the just
happened and she's like mom I have no
clue the charges form one of the biggest
murder cases ever brought against a US
healthcare professional this breach of a
doctors oath is vile and worthy of
today's actions and that begins the
process of holding this accused killer
criminally accountable
but Houston's attorney says his client
never intended to speed up any patients
death I think it's important that
everyone watching this understand that
the patients that we're talking about
our end-of-life patients were going to
die whether doctor he was always on or
whether another doctor who was on the
hospital involved Mount Carmel health
system tipped off the authorities here
to use those actions after they
conducted their own internal
investigation they continue to cooperate
with law enforcement employees who
helped administer the drugs are no
longer treating patients no other
charges have been filed in this case but
it's worth noting that prosecutors
credited the family members with helping
them with their investigation if you can
imagine seeing a family member who lost
someone well you know you have to tell
the investigators what happened what
didn't you still say what did you know
you do what did you say back what do you
tell family members the same thing you
know it's interesting when we
interviewed the family members a few
months ago that was striking to me that
many of them said you know they told us
that our loved one he told us that our
loved one was brain dead we couldn't
understand how suddenly they were brain
dead so quickly and the big question is
always why why why haven't said the
motive prosecutors said they don't know
a no thank you
we'll continue to follow this story